il se passe quelque chose de spécial à
granby ces jours ci et c'est bien plus
que l'esprit des fêtes qui s'installe il
y à un élan de solidarité sans précédent
le salut bonjour comment puis-je vous
aider enfin vous êtes vraiment
d'accompagner les gens pour les
bénévoles se manifestent avec un
sentiment d'urgence à la hauteur des
besoins
on est vendue à une liste de 57
personnes qui veulent les délais serrés
juin où elle est et son équipe ont tout
organisé
l'école la garderie les papiers tout
pour accueillir et fournir le nécessaire
à 70,6 rien qui ne connaissent personne
au canada et qui dès leur arrivée auront
droit à l'aide sociale
le temps de trouver du travail tels nous
à s'organiser pour avoir un logement
adéquat pour que la personne plus que se
nourrir puis un peu avoir reste de ces
choses pour vire
elle attend impatiemment les premières
familles qui devrait atterrir à tout
moment on voit les accueillir ici on va
aller les mener dans leur appartement
le soir même oui vous souriez
oui j'ai hâte
pourquoi avoir choisi cet appartement
certains domaines mais plus beaux
appartements il ya un très très belle
vue mais dit il suffit et propriétaire
d'un immeuble à logements il sait
exactement ce que c'est que d'atterrir
dans l'inconnu il a fui son coût sauve
natale j'écoutais les mange ses choeurs
stocker larry cinq ans brad may perdu et
c'est pourquoi il est réservé trois
appartements pour des familles syriennes
qui comme lui devront rebâtir leur vie
je travaillais beaucoup vraiment beau
les messages pour tout les nouveaux
arrivants j'aimerais bien dire aux
autres aussi les morales et puis pensées
positives et vous êtes dans un terrain
d'accueil et des possibilités au canada
il imagine déjà une grande famille ici
les enfants de la vie il reste juste à
avoir des meubles mais ça je sais que
c'est aussi parce qu'il l'a vécue que le
simple citoyen peut faire toute la
différence
tout le monde va aider des meubles tous
à sa part question c'est moralement
moralement retard avec eux
jean luc p très justement devenu un
modèle dans la communauté à granby
pour ce qui est de l'accompagnement des
réfugiés le jumelage pour moi là c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas compliqué ça
ne coûte rien c'est ça coûte quelque
chose oui matin son concept est tout
simple il applique depuis des années
s'est jumelée à une famille de réfugiés
pour au moins un an
être là pour eux dès qu'ils mettent les
pieds dans leur nouvel environnement
pour la première fois à l'eau on a
quelqu'un qui vont en faire
l'interprétation de nos propos ok entre
les deux familles et concrètement ça
veut dire que le lendemain lorsque je
vais aller chez eux les voir on voit que
je comprends je vais avoir un outil
informatique avec gogo l'image gogol
vidéo google traduction
mes mains mon visage et on va
communiquer comme ça c'est ça
concrètement il son modèle a fait du
chemin
cent soixante dix familles de la région
se sont offertes pour guider des
réfugiés syriens
serge courtemanche un jeune retraité qui
a du temps c'est inscrit sans hésiter je
garde son pc souffre un peu moins de
facilité dans son d'horreur toujours
leur atterrissage à grand baie et comme
bien d'autres il est prêt à recevoir une
famille syrienne à la maison pour fêter
le réveillon
pourquoi ne seraient pas de faire en
sorte que eux aussi il peut aussi goûter
à une forme de sérénité de graduelle
même sérénité donc transférés ont
vraiment bien besoin de que dans six
mois je disais mais finalement cette
porte s'est fait comme ça que ça s'est
passé ça a été j'ai eu des moments plus
difficiles
je m'y attends mais bon vous êtes là ça
pour ça je suis versant pour ça mais dit
il suffit aussi s'assure que oui et que
oui je vais faire le même trajet
qu'est ce qu'est la mort de granby en
fait pas moins et ses yeux brillent
quand il parle de la rue principale de
la montagne du lac telles qu'il les a
découvert un jour d'automne il y à 16